renforcement musculaire mais les
contacts finies les vacances rugby-club
de versailles équipes seniors est en
pleine préparation à l'aube d'une
nouvelle saison du championnat ile de
france honneur un travail intensif en
vue de réaliser les grandes ambitions du
club
l'objectif est clair cela n'est il faut
qu'on remonte en fait pas et globalement
avec les joueurs le groupe quand elle en
train de mettre en place
on a tous les ingrédients pour pouvoir y
arriver alors après évidemment il ya
tout ce qui peut arriver à intervenir
sur tout pendant la poule est aussi du
club aux six ans qui sont renforcées
parmi les clubs qui se sont renforcées
on retrouve notamment l'équipe de
sarcelles la structure investi plusieurs
milliers d'euros pour créer une équipe
capable de monter les seniors au niveau
fédéral et pour le coach alain jamin il
faudra aussi rester concentré face aux
autres équipes de cette poule 2 je pense
qu'il ya bagneux qui peut encore jouer
le trouble-fête comme la saison dernière
à bagneux équipe toujours difficile à
jouer
après il ya d'autres équipes vitry on
avait perdu chez eux je pense que cette
année c'est pareil il avait un nouveau
staff l'an dernier cette année ils ont
une vie une année en commun aussi fort
je pense que sur le papier a priori
travers la sarcelle et versailles mais
je pense qu'on a d'autres derrière qui
sont pas loin ça va être une poule à mon
avis encore assez homogène comme la
saison dernière pour réussir à tenir son
rang et à lutter pour les premières
places le rcv a décidé de recruter et
d'intégrer des jeunes afin d'étoffer son
groupe
aujourd'hui près de 80 joueurs sont à la
disposition du coach
on avait juste un effectif juste on a
pendant une partie de la saison on a été
obligé de faire jouer les lascars
réserves pratiquement il a 3 3 joueurs
par poste complètement différentes qui
va se jouer
premier match de la saison pour verser
le dimanche 1er octobre sur le terrain
de gif-sur-yvette la saison dernière en
honneur versailles avait débuté par
trois défaites consécutives